Bitte schön.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Chewick.
Ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sehen Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, klar.
Okay, kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann direkt auch zu Ihrer Beschwerde übergehen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie mir bitte eine Zeichen.
Dann machen wir eine kurze Pause, okay?
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Kevin Jaeger.
Könnten Sie mir bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname kurz buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist K-E-V-I-N Kevin
und Jaeger-J-A-Umlaut-G-E-R Jaeger.
Herr Jaeger, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
12.08.2003.
Ich werde also in kürze 19 Jahre.
12.08.
2003, genau.
Okay, und wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit, Herr Jaeger?
Nicht so viel, 67 Kilo.
67, und wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 Meter.
80, okay.
Und sind Sie ledig, oder?
Ja, ja, ich bin ledig.
Und okay, welche Beschwerde haben Sie, Herr Jaeger?
Ich habe schon so lange Fieber und fühle mich eigentlich schlecht
und ich habe irgendwie ganz stark Beschwerden beim Schlucken.
Also ich habe immer so ein Widerstandsgefühl und es tut auch weh
und die, ja ich habe Kopfschmerzen, ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen
und ich habe das Gefühl, dass hier so die Lymphknoten angeschwollen sind.
Ja, das fühle ich hier so am Hals, ne?
Ja, und ich fühle mich total schlapp
und nachdem das schon so lange geht, habe ich gedacht,
ich muss mich doch mal dringend zum Arzt gehen.
Okay, und seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Das geht ja schon die dritte Woche.
Dritte Woche? Ja.
Okay, und Ihre Beschwerden sind anhaltend oder geht es manchmal weg?
Nein, das ist eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit,
wenn ich mich so schlapp fühle und auch, dass ich diese komischen
Halsschmerzen habe oder dieses Klosgefühl so.
Und Ihre Lymphknoten, ist schmerzhaft oder schmerzlos?
Das tut auch ein bisschen weh, ja.
Also ich merke es, dass die dick sind
und ja, auf Druck ist das auch ein bisschen schmerzhaft.
Und sind diese Lymphknoten hart oder weich?
Zum Beispiel wie Gummi oder?
Ich glaube, eher weich. Weich.
Das müssen Sie dann selber machen, versuchen, glaube ich.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, und könnten Sie mir bitte Ihre Kopf- oder Bauchschmerzen
beschreiben, stechen, drückend oder wellenvoll, mich krampfartig?
Ja, eher drückend, würde ich sagen, drückend.
Und links im Bauch, so habe ich so ein Druckgefühl auch.
Okay, und haben Sie zu Hause Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe das mal gemessen, da war das fast bei 39.
39, okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Übelkeit,
Erbrochen, Husten, Atemnot?
Nee, sowas habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nur dieses völlig K.O. fühlen, dass ich mich so schlapp fühle.
Okay, und haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen oder Muskelkater?
Nee, das würde ich jetzt nicht so sagen.
Das Gefühl habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Okay, und gibt es etwas, was diese Beschwerde verstärkt oder liest?
Zum Beispiel Ihre Schluckbeschwerden, nach dem Essen oder nach Hartigen
oder Festigen oder Flüssigkeit essen, diese Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, diese Zeiten rutschen besser.
Ja, wie immer, wenn man so ein bisschen Schluckbeschwerden,
kühle Sachen rutschen besser als warme.
Und ich meine, jetzt ist es sowieso draußen warm, da trinkt man gerne was Kühles.
Aber tatsächlich bin ich ein bisschen kaufeu,
und esse lieber Sachen, die so ein bisschen weich sind.
Okay, aber haben Sie nie erbrochen, oder?
Nee, übergeben musste ich mich nicht, nein.
Okay, gut, und wenn wir eine Schmerzskala haben,
von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr geringe, 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen,
wie schätzen die Schmerzen ein Kopf und Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, vielleicht zwischen 4 und 6, würde ich sagen, je nach Tagesform.
Okay, und strahlen die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus?
Herr Jäger?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, und sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Eigentlich bin ich ja noch so jung, ich habe eigentlich sonst nichts.
Ich meine, ich habe schon so ein paar Unfälle gehabt.
Also ich hatte mal eine gebrochene Nasenscheidewein, da habe ich ein Schlacht drauf bekommen.
Und als Kind hatte ich mal eine Sorge.
Wurde Sie schon mal operiert gegen Schade, Nasenscheideweindfraktur?
Ja, das ist gerichtet worden, aber das ist auch schon wieder 2 Jahre her, 3 Jahre her.
Und jetzt habe ich seit kurzem, ja seit 5 Wochen,
ist die Achillesäne an dem einen Bein ein bisschen entzündet.
Und als ganz kleines Baby hatte ich mal eine Lungenentzündung,
das haben meine Eltern mir erzählt.
Und was ich tatsächlich nicht gut vertragen kann,
ich kriege von Sonnenbestrahlung ein Ausschlag.
Ich muss also die Sonnenbestrahlung vermeiden,
muss mich entweder gut einkremen oder eben Sonnenhut tragen, Sonnenbrille,
weil ich sonst Probleme kriege.
Okay, hatten Sie vorher ähnliche Beschwerden, Herr Jäger?
Nein, so schlecht ist es mir überhaupt noch nie gegangen.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasser lassen?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Das fällt mir schon auf, ich habe ordentlich Blähungen.
Das hatte ich früher glaube ich nicht,
aber das ist im Augenblick schon so ein bisschen unangenehm.
Jetzt haben Sie Blähungen.
Okay, aber haben Sie keine Beschwerde beim Stuhlgang oder Wasser?
Beim Stuhlgang selber nicht, das sieht alles normal aus.
Okay, und hat sich Ihre Gewicht in letzter Zeit oder Ihre Appetit verändert?
Ja, der Appetit ist im Augenblick nicht so doll, das stimmt schon,
aber ich glaube ich habe nicht noch abgenommen.
Aber haben Sie ein bisschen Appetitlosigkeit in letzter Zeit?
Ja, einfach weil ich so schlecht drauf bin, schmeckt einem das Essen nicht.
Und haben Sie Nachtschweiß, Herr Jäger?
Nein, schwitzen tu ich nicht.
Schwitzen tu ich nicht, aber ich schlafe nicht wirklich gut.
Also ich schlafe unruhig zur Zeit.
Beim Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Beim Durchschlafen würde ich sagen.
Durchschlafen gegen Schmerzen oder der andere?
Ich weiß, ich kann es gar nicht sagen, was mich aufweckt, aber irgendwie bin ich unruhig nachts.
Okay, und haben Sie Stress bei der Schule oder zu Hause?
Eigentlich nicht so besonders.
Bei der Ausbildung hat man immer Stress, aber jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Okay, und haben Sie Rückenschmerzen, Herr Jäger?
Rückenschmerzen?
Nein, der Rückenschmerz tut nicht weh, nicht eher so der Bau.
Okay, und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, operiert wurde ich noch nie.
Okay, und sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Covid und auch Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, als Kind, da bin ich natürlich gegen alles Mögliche geimpft worden,
und jetzt gegen Covid bin ich auch komplett geimpft.
Ja, das ist gut für Sie.
Okay, und gibt es in Ihrer Familie besondere Krankheiten?
Ja, meine Mutter, die hat ein Diabetes, auch relativ ausgeprägt,
obwohl sie ja noch gar nicht so alt ist.
Die hat auch schon ein bisschen Probleme an den Augen,
dass die Netzhaut ein bisschen geschädigt ist.
Und mein Vater ist ganz jung gestorben.
Der hatte ein Schilddrösenkrebs, der ist nur 43 Jahre alt geworden.
43 Jahre alt, das tut mir sehr leid, herzliches Beileid,
Frau Herr Jäger, gegen Schilddrösenkrebs, okay.
Ja.
Und haben Sie feuchte Hände oder zum Beispiel trockene Haut?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Oder Haarausfall zum Beispiel?
Haar ausfallen? Ach nicht, nein.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Herzschlagen, Herzpochen stolpern in letzter Zeit?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig?
Ja, also wegen der Haut muss ich manchmal Cortisonsalve nehmen,
wenn das gerade irgendwie doch ein bisschen viel Sonne abbekommen hat.
Und dann habe ich jetzt auch mal versucht,
gegen das Fieberparazetamol zu nehmen und gegen die Kopfschmerzen,
aber das hat nicht wirklich viel gebracht.
Aber das habe ich eigentlich immer im Haus, wenn mal was ist.
Okay, und trauen Sie, Herr Jäger?
Ja, regelmäßig rauchen tu ich nicht.
Ich rauch hin und wieder mal mit, was weiß ich, wenn ein Test ist oder so,
aber regelmäßig rauchen tu ich nicht.
Okay, und seit wann?
Ja, solange darf ich ja noch nicht, aber ja, so,
vielleicht so seit ich 16 bin, also drei Jahre,
aber wirklich nur sehr sporadisch.
Aber nicht regelmäßig, okay.
Ja, dann will ich nur hin und wieder mal.
Okay, gut.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, auch da, also kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben so neben der Arbeit,
also hin und wieder mal, wenn ein Test ist oder wenn man zusammen sitzt,
was weiß ich, Besuch hat oder so, dann trinke ich mal zwei Bier oder so,
aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie die Frage nicht persönlich, ich muss diese Frage alle
Patienten stellen.
Hatten Sie irgendwann einmal mit Drogenkontakt, Herr Jäger?
Mit Drogen?
Nee, das war auch ein Schulhof, immer verkauft worden,
aber ich habe dann eben mitgemacht.
Nein, nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts, keine Erfahrung.
Und außer Sonnenbestrahlung sind bei Ihnen irgendwie
Alergie oder Unverträglichkeit, Becker?
Ja, ich habe noch Heuchknupfen, also im Frühling, weil wenn die
Gräserpollen unterwegs sind, dann…
Gräse und Polen, Sie haben…
Gräserpollen, ja.
Okay, und wie…
Wie aussetzt sich die Verlängerung?
Ja, dann habe ich halt eine Laufnase und so Schnupfen
und die Augen sind auch so ein bisschen gerötet.
Okay, gut.
Ich kontrolliere sofort.
Okay, Schwere Lämpfüßigkeit, Abschmerzen.
Okay, ich habe alle meine wichtige Frage gestattet, Herr Jäger,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, möchte natürlich jetzt gerne wissen, was mir los ist.
Es ist ja kein Zustand, dass ich so rumhänge.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich Urlaub machen
und das kann ich ja so gar nicht.
Aber was ist denn los mit mir?
Was kann das denn sein?
Nicht, dass ich auch irgendwie, wie mein Vater,
eine Gräbserkrankung habe.
Da habe ich natürlich ein bisschen Angst davor.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich kann Sie nachvollziehen, Herr Jäger.
Aber ja, ich möchte Sie beruhigen,
weil Gräbs ist nicht 100 Prozent erblich ist.
Aber natürlich, wir müssen kontrollieren,
Ihre Heilsbereiche und Ihre Schilddröse.
Aber das kann mehrere Ursachen haben.
Es ist zu früh, um etwas zu sagen.
Und deswegen, bevor ich etwas Faltes sage,
würde ich abwarten,
bis ich die Untersuchungen durchgeführt habe, Herr Jäger.
Was machen Sie denn für Untersuchungen?
Ja, zuerst natürlich,
muss ich die körperliche Untersuchung und dann Blut abnehmen.
Und dann eigentlich, ich würde eine Ultraschall im Heilsbereich,
besonders Schilddröse Ultraschall, anfordern.
Und nach der Untersuchung oder nach der Ergebnisse
können wir wieder über Ihre Diagnose
und Behandlung sprechen.
Okay, das klingt vernünftig, ja.
Okay, danke sehr.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Einige gleich.
Ich habe wieder vergissene.
Sie sind nicht verreiratet,
haben aber eine Freundin mit der Sie zusammen sind.
Ah, super.
Das stimmt, ja, woher wissen Sie, dass er gut ist?
Ja.
Okay.
Er hat tatsächlich eine Freundin
und das Besondere ist,
diese Freundin ist auch kramm.
Die hat die gleichen Symptome.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Heiserkeit?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie eine Wunde im Mund?
Mund?
Nein, nein.
Gibt es eine Veränderung in Ihrem Körper?
Was für Veränderungen?
Veränderung.
Ach so, nein.
Ich habe eine Veränderung.
Die Farben sind normal, würde ich sagen.
Da ist nichts anders.
Wenn ich Fieber habe,
dass ich eine rote Birne habe,
dass ich einen roten Kopf habe.
Wenn ich so Fieber habe.
Aber sonst nicht.
Danke schön.
Hallo, Herr Kollege.
Noch eine Frage.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon auf der Spur?
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Entschuldigung?
Haben Sie eine Spur?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, ja, gut.
Okay.
Ja, aber nach...
Die Frage von...
Herr Gündus.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Ich war geil.
Ich war geil mit der Intensivität.
Ich war geil mit der Information.
Ja, geh nicht zu.
Herr Gündus,
haben Sie die Patienten im Computer-Unternahmen abgelegt?
Oder haben Sie die alle im Kopf?
Alle im Kopf.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Ja, also...
Sie kann man nicht hinter das Licht führen.
Einmal, einmal,
lässt er fünf Monate
mit uns zusammen
in der Spur.
Mit uns zusammen, ja.
Zweimal sogar.
Nein, fünf Monate haben Sie recht.
Mit Frau Gürbis haben wir den einmal gemacht.
Ja.
Und im Januar einmal mit Emre.
Emre, ja.
Ja.
Wahnsinn.
Also unglaublich, dass Sie das alles noch wissen,
sagenhaft.
Ich weiß das nicht mehr.
Ja, super.
Ich muss tatsächlich immer erst wieder nachlesen.
Wobei, dann fallen mir die Details schon auch wieder ein.
Und, ja, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn es losgehen kann.
Okay.
Wie können wir anfangen, wenn Sie möchten?
Ja, ich hoffe, ich kann es schaffen.
Okay.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
Sehr gut, ja.
Okay.
Kevin Jaeger.
Ein Moment.
Ich habe wieder vergessen.
19 Jahre.
Stellte sich bei uns wegen
seit drei Wochen
bestehender,
anhaltender,
Fieber,
Schluckstörungen
und
auch drückende
linkseitige Bauchschmerzen
vor.
Die Schmerzintensität
wurde mit
vier oder fünf
von zehn bewertet.
Er klagte auch
über
schmerzhafte und weiche
Lämpfknochen
im
Schmerz- und
Schmerz-Lämpfknochen
und
Fattig.
Er
erwähnte
zu Hause
seine Temperatur
gemessen
und
er könne
Flüssigkeit
und Weichessen
essen.
Er hatte
die
Schmerz-Lämpfknochen
und
er konnte
nicht so einfach
werden.
Genau.
Früher
habe er keine ähnliche
Beschwerden
und
die Frage
nach
Auslandsreisen
wurde verneint.
An
Vorerkrankungen
war unauffällig.
Nur früher
wurde bei
ihm
eine Achilleszene-
Infektion festgestellt,
aber zurzeit
habe er keine Beschwerde
und
er wurde keine operiert.
Er wurde noch nicht operiert.
Er
hat
Nasen-
Septalfraktur
gelitten.
Er
ist vollständig geimpft.
In der Familienanmense
fanden sich
Mutter Diabetes mellitus
und
auch Makulatogeneration.
Und bei Vater
leider ist er
eine Drohitkarcinoma gestorben
mit
43 Jahre.
Vegetativ an am Nese
war unauffällig
bis auf
nur Durchlaufstörungen
und seine Appetit
in letzter Zeit ein bisschen
verändert
und in er
Appetitlosigkeit aber nicht so
eingesträngt.
Genau.
Und
er
in Bezug auf Medikamente
nehmt er
oder wendet er nur
gegen Haut
bei
Sonnenbestrahlung
eine Cortisolbe an
und manchmal bei Bedarf
gegen Kopfschmerzen
und Fieber, Paracetamol
und
er rauche
nicht regelmäßig aber
hin und wieder.
Er raucht seit ungefähr 3 Jahren
er trinke
nicht regelmäßig Alkohol
und die Frage
nach Drogen wurden verneint.
Bei
ihm
sind Allergien
nur gegen
Gräse und Polen
bekannt
und auch Sonnenbestrahlung
die Allergischreaktion
äußert sich
Hautausschlag
Nasenverstopfung
und gerötete Nase
ja, das was
und
ja, kann ich
meine Verdachtdiagnose sagen?
Ja.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Angaben
gehe ich vom Verdacht auf
EBW-Infektionen
aus
aber natürlich
zum Ausschluss von
Triotkartinoma
muss man
Triot Ultraschall antworten
ja wegen
Familiegeschichte
ja
und
differenziell diagnostisch
kommen
Toncilitis
Pharyngitis
auch
die schlimmste Situation
Triotalcarcinoma
in Betracht kommen
oder auch
was wäre noch denkbar
junger Mann
geschwollene Lymphknoten
Lymphoma könnte sein
genau, Hotschkin
oder non-Hotschkin
könnte sein
und zu weiteren Abkühlerung
empfehle ich Folgende untersuchen
und Labore ist sehr wichtig
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, Lymphknoten
Abtasten ist sehr wichtig
Konsistenz
Farbe oder zum Beispiel
Große ist sehr wichtig
und
leider ich habe total vergessen
wie
hat
oder haben die Schwellen oder ihre Lymphknoten
in letzter Zeit verändert
als Große
aber natürlich, wir müssen gucken
Ja, das merken Sie
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung dann
Okay
aber wovonach gucken Sie noch
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung direkt?
Eigentlich Bauchabtasten
ist sehr wichtig, weil
bei der EBB-Infektion
kann man große
oder kleine
Megali abtasten
und deswegen, wir müssen überprüfen
und
ja, und wenn
mein Verdachtdiagnos bestätigt wird
natürlich
Was machen Sie denn
erst noch
bevor Sie
behandeln?
Ne, bevor Sie behandeln,
aber was machen Sie labortechnisch denn?
Labortechnisch, ja
Wir können
EBB
Antikörper überprüfen
und auch
wir müssen
Leberwerte kontrollieren
und
kleines Blutbild
CRP und DSG ist sehr wichtig
Wir müssen natürlich gucken
Es gibt ein Schnelltest
Bei Gündis hat das gerade reingestellt
der, ich glaube, die Antikörper zeigt, ne?
Ja
Wie heißt denn
diese
Infektion mit dem vollen Namen?
Was gibt es für andere Bezeichnungen
dafür?
Wie sagen Sie?
Wir sagen
noch ein bisschen
da noch ein bisschen wissenschaftlicher
dann
Infektionuses
anti-nsei
Ah, ja guck mal. Herr Günther sagt Studentenfieber.
Das ist die abgeschwächte Version von Kissing Disease.
Ja, genau.
Okay, gut.
Bei Kindern kann man mit viele bösartige Erkrankungen verwechseln.
Und deswegen, eigentlich Blutausstich ist sehr wichtig.
Wir können überprüfen Blutzelle.
Und nach der Blutausstich kann man einfach oder mehr klar sagen oder sprechen.
Ja, genau.
Gut, wenn sich das bestätigt, was ist denn die Therapie?
Ja, eigentlich, wir empfehlen normalerweise, es ist symptomatische Therapie oder Behandlung.
Und ungefähr nach 10 Tagen oder 2 Wochen geht alles wieder besser und normal.
Natürlich Flüssigkeit, Gabel oder Paracetamol.
Ja, genau.
Kann man nehmen.
Und wie ist das mit körperlicher Belastung?
Ja, natürlich muss man zu Hause bleiben und ja, man sollte nicht belasten, körperliche Belasten besonders.
Worauf muss man insbesondere achten, auch in der nächsten Zeit?
Eigentlich.
Was bleibt eigentlich noch relativ lange, so ein bisschen sensibel?
Die Milz bleibt noch relativ lange sensibel?
Man sollte nicht gerade boxen oder etwas, was ich baue, gefährliche Sport.
Ja, genau, wegen Spendermeggeli oder der andere.
Genau, dass man diese ohnehin geschwollene Milz nicht noch durch den Trauma irgendwie in Gefahr bringt.
Ja, genau.
Für Milzstruktur muss man darauf achten.
Sie haben das recht.
Gut, hier waren noch ein paar Fragen.
Was spricht gegen, was spricht gegen, ein Oesophagus-Kartinum?
Spricht gegen, ja, genau.
Was ja gegen spricht?
Eigentlich Fieber, Bauchschmerzen.
Genau.
Sprechen für Oesophagus-Kartinum gegen.
Und ja, eigentlich nur vielleicht Schilddrüse, der auch Trauit-Kartinum ist, muss man natürlich ausschließen.
Genau, da haben die Grüfer auch nachgefasst, gibt es ein erhöhtes Risiko,
gibt es ein erhöhtes Risiko, weil der Vater ein Schilddrüsenkartinum hatte.
Die sagen, es gibt keine genetische Predisposition.
Das, ja, wahrscheinlich ist das auch so ein bisschen Meinungsgeschichte.
Also, die Grüfer haben gesagt, es gibt für Schilddrüsenkartinum keine Predisposition.
Aber ich denke mal, die individuelle Sensibilität, also die individuelle Angst ist einfach da.
Ja, weil die Leute das kennen und die Symptome kennen.
Und insofern würde man natürlich in solch einem Fall immer sehr genau hingucken
und auf alle Fälle da einen Ausschluss machen.
Natürlich.
Ja, gut, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt, ob sich das bestätigt,
dass der Herr Jäger wirklich mononucleose hat.
Halten Sie mich über die Ergebnisse bitte auf dem Laufenden.
Und dann schauen wir, der kann aber dann wieder nach Hause gehen, ne?
Ja, natürlich.
Der kann nach Hause, muss ich aber in Quarantäne begeben.
Genau, und zu Hause bleiben.
Gut, alles da.
Alles da.
Gut.
Danke sehr.
Wir haben wieder eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht und Sie haben auch eine sehr schöne Präsentation gemacht.
Wirklich.
Danke sehr.
Vielen Dank.
Also, ich würde sagen, da gibt es nichts dran zu meckern.
Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Gündel, was sagen Sie?
Sehr gut Anamnese gemacht hat.
Danke.
Ja.
Also, auch wenn Sie jetzt eine Woche lang Ruhe vor mir haben am nächsten Donnerstag, also Donnerstag in einer Woche, das läuft.
Ja?
Gut.